E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
é um e 52 de altura acima do peso
cabelos e olhos castanhos e com algumas
características físicas peculiares
os estou com os cabelos soltos e um
vestido na cor rosa um tão bem clarinho
uma cor aconchegante como um abraço de
Mãe essa é a minha áudio descrição é uma
importante ferramenta utilizada para que
as pessoas com deficiência visual me
conheçam assim como a maioria de vocês
me ver nesse momento
é a responsável por essas minhas
características físicas peculiares é
conhecida como síndrome de Brida
congênita nome bonito né No meu caso ela
provocou deformidades nas mãos e
ausência de parte da perna direita
apesar da síndrome eu tive uma infância
muito feliz
cercada de amigos e uma família muito
carinhosa nasci numa cidadezinha no
interior de Santa Catarina e confesso
para vocês que por muito tempo eu não
fazia ideia do que era ser vista como
pessoa com deficiência
até nos mudarmos para Jaraguá do Sul a
ficha caiu quando eu entrei em um ônibus
lotado e fiquei em pé me segurando perto
daqueles bancos preferenciais
logo percebi um senhor lá do alto dos
seus setenta e poucos anos olhando o
Curioso as minhas mãos não demorou muito
e ele puxou assunto disse assim
a minha filha que pena é uma moça tão
bonita como você com Esses dedinhos
assim eu expliquei a ele que tava tudo
bem que eu trabalhava e estudava e que
essa condição física não me pedia de
nada não convencido com a minha
explicação ele pegou
carinhosamente nas minhas mãos e disse
não fique triste minha filha Pior é se
tivesse nascido sem uma perninha eu não
contei aquele simpático senhor que sim
eu havia nascido sem uma perninha Afinal
como convencê-lo que tava tudo bem como
explicar que se tudo no mundo fosse
pensado e criado para todos eu não teria
nenhuma dificuldade e acredito que foi
por isso porque ele é provar que nós
pessoas com deficiência podemos ter uma
vida normal e merecemos viver em um
mundo pensado e criado para todos eu
decidi estudar
a pintura e urbanismo eu me lembro que
desde o início da faculdade e assuntos
como acessibilidade urbanismo cidade
para as pessoas eram os que mais me
chamavam a atenção mas investe para de
TCC eu ainda não fazia ideia do que
seria o meu projeto mas tinha certeza
que queria criar algo para melhorar a
vida das pessoas em especial das pessoas
com deficiência
e se foi no final de tarde no outono de
2014 que a ideia surgiu eu sempre vi
aquele grupo de crianças brincando no
parquinho da escola em um dos balanços
uma menininha a Karina devido a diversas
síndromes Karina não andava não falava
não se alimentava sozinha e precisava de
ajuda para Praticamente tudo inclusive
para brincar no seu brinquedo preferido
Apesar de todas as dificuldades Karina
se expressavam de maneira ímpar eu me
lembro que ela até fechava os olhinhos
enquanto se balançava parece que para
sentir melhor o vento batendo no seu
rosto
essa cena se repetiu por muitas e muitas
vezes
e até que um dia no final de tarde de
outono o balança estava vazio
Karina havia crescido e não cabia mais
naquele balanço e como não existia
nenhum outro brinquedo acessível na
escola ela ficava ali no cantinho do
Parque limitada a sua cadeira de rodas
enquanto via as outras crianças
brincarem bom se isso te parece Cruel
imagine a cena da Ótica de uma criança
que não conseguia entender o porquê de
não poder mais brincar com o seu
brinquedo preferido foi nesse instante
que eu decidi que o meu TCC seria sobre
brinquedos acessíveis para que todas as
crianças pudessem brincar juntas e
fossem felizes da mesma forma que eu fui
Quando contei para minha orientadora ela
ficou super empolgada com a ideia mas
com uma única palavra ela me fez entrar
em Pânico ela me disse assim eu amei
essa ideia Cris Mas aonde você vai
instalar em não
precisa pensar em um espaço acessível
Talvez pensar em um grande Parque Urbano
para Jaraguá do Sul
cara do céu eu só quero criar brinquedos
e não projetar um parque pensei comigo
mas como metade da nota do TCC era essa
professora quem dava eu respondi plena
Claro Professor eu vou estudar a cidade
encontrar a melhor o melhor local para
instalar os brinquedos é eu realmente
não sabia onde eu estava me metendo mas
como a minha mãe sempre diz eu tenho
muito mais sorte do que juízo Na época
eu fazia estágio no instituto de
planejamento da Prefeitura de Jaraguá do
Sul o que me permitiu estudar a cidade
em diferentes aspectos e apesar de hoje
Jaraguá ser conhecida como um grande
polo industrial ela nasceu como Colônia
Agrícola as ocupações surgirão nas
margens dos cursos d'água em meio a
grandes parcelas de terra que era
utilizada a altura Jaraguá foi crescendo
crescendo muitas indústrias se
instalaram no município e com essa
crescente industrialização
muitas pessoas migraram do campo para
Cidade o que fez surgir a necessidade de
criar espaços adequados para atender a
nova demanda da população mas se de um
lado existe a necessidade de criar
espaços adequados do outro existe uma
cidade marcada pela topografia irregular
diversas condicionantes ambientais e uma
mancha Urbana descontínua com ocupação
rarefeita e meio a extenso os vazios
urbanos é a professora tinha razão com
esse cenário era realmente preciso
pensar em algo para reconectar trazer
uso para esses vazios urbanos e aí sim
criar espaços para instalar os
brinquedos acessíveis vocês devem estar
se perguntando como fazer isso tudo em
um projeto de TCC como que seria
possível reconecta e pode ir ao mesmo
tempo criar espaços acessíveis
vão a resposta era uma só urbanismo
acessível engana-se quem acredita que
urbanismo acessível refere-se apenas a
rampas e pisos táteis um ele é fruto de
um esforço coletivo é o resultado de
pensar a cidade junto com os atores
principais as pessoas todas as pessoas
independente da condição física de cada
um foi então que o Nino experiência como
pessoa com deficiência a paixão pelo
urbanismo e principalmente por acreditar
que espaços acessíveis são fundamentais
na relação entre as pessoas que criamos
o que na época foi chamado de Parque
Linear Ilha da Figueira o processo Foi
incrível os limites do parque e surgiram
de forma natural e Meio às montanhas e
rios elementos muito marcante na
paisagem do município as áreas de
preservação permanente em casas como o
grande Monções que acomodam as águas do
rio itapocu em épocas de Cheias a
implantação de novas conexões viárias as
ciclovias e as pistas de caminhada foram
projetados para minimizar os impactos
causados pelos grandes polos geradores
de tráfego os quais comprometem até hoje
a acessibilidade EA mobilidade urbana o
programa de necessidades do Parque
Linear Ilha da Figueira foi desenvolvido
Com base no desenho Universal utilizando
critérios de projeto que buscam atender
ao maior número de pessoas possível com
autonomia e segurança
tudo ali foi pensado para todos os
passeios e ciclovias livres de
obstáculos quadras de esporte pista de
skate horta e Bosque comunitários E é
claro os brinquedos acessíveis
projetados para que possam ser
utilizados por crianças e adultos em
cadeira de rodas de forma segura e
autônoma sem o horário de ajuda de outra
pessoa além disso foram previstos muitos
muitos espaços de encontro e troca de
vivências pensados para que as pessoas
se conectam em uma com as outras com as
suas particularidades e Contemple o que
há de mais belo na vida as diferenças
isso tudo poderia ser apenas um projeto
de TCC Utopia de Uma arquiteta Maluco e
Sonhadora mas não não para Jaraguá do
Sul e com base em discussões e Estudos
técnicos que iniciaram muito antes de eu
pensar em entrar na faculdade com
iniciativa do setor público
principalmente da fundação do meio
ambiente diversos setores da sociedade
inclusive do Ministério Público em 2019
foi inaugurada a primeira etapa do que
conhecemos hoje como Parque Via Verde
uma área antes desvalorizada marcada por
inundações e restrições ambientais É
hoje um o comentador do crescimento e do
desenvolvimento econômico e urbano de
Jaraguá do Sul É verdade que ainda há
muito a se fazer para tornar Jaraguá uma
cidade para todos mas um grande passo já
foi dado hoje eu sinto que de alguma
forma esse Parque representa a
realização de um sonho sonhado por
muitos a Karina a inspiração para os
brinquedos acessíveis infelizmente não
chegou a conhecer o Parque Via Verde mas
Esteja onde você estiver saiba que essa
responsável por estar aqui contando essa
história no palco do Tex obrigada
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]